la oleada de ataques de colonos
israelíes contra aldeas palestinas y la
expansión de los asentamientos israelíes
en los territorios ocupados han
despertado críticas de la comunidad
internacional el secretario de estado
estadounidense Anthony blinken dijo
haber transmitido su preocupación por
las agresiones de colonos Es que la
semana pasada entraron en más de una
decena de poblaciones palestinas algunos
de ellos armados causando incendios y
destruyendo cientos de casas y vehículos
de su diálogo con el ministro de
exteriores israelí y laicohen blinken
obtuvo la promesa de que Israel tomará
medidas contra aquellos que en palabras
del canciller israelí se toman la
justicia por su mano esto luego de una
de las semanas más mortíferas del año en
Jordania con 17 palestinos muertos y
otros cuatro israelíes lo que también
motivó discursos de varios
representantes del Consejo de Seguridad
de la ONU preocupados por esta violencia
y por la aprobación de 5.400 nuevas
viviendas en asentamientos israelíes de
sijordania ocupada estas unidades a más
de 13 mil las nuevas construcciones
aprobadas en 2023 un récord anual que
Israel alcanzó en solo seis meses a
pesar de que la ONU considera los
asentamientos ilegales y un obstáculo
para la paz el representante israelí
para Naciones Unidas dijo que las
construcciones no se detendrán una
muestra más de cómo el gobierno israelí
de extrema derecha continúa destruyendo
las críticas y a la vez no se pone de
acuerdo en cómo abordar la violencia de
los colonos un ejemplo es que anoche en
una reunión de gabinete de urgencia y
como revelaron medios israelíes el
ministro de seguridad interior el
extremista itamar benhibir calificó de
niños dulces a los pocos jóvenes
arrestados por las agresiones mientras
los jefes de defensa e inteligencia le
recriminaron su apoyo tácito a los
ataques